[Music]
selfmade has to be somebody that was
growing up broke I disagree with that
you can mow lawns for a few months and
make like a few thousand dollars we know
how many lawns I'm gonna have tomorrow
it's a lot of lawns multimillionaire
please welcome Tim Sykes the key to my
success is just working hard like 18 to
20 hour days every day of my life and
having no life but having a lot of money
I think it's consistency waking up every
day doing things that I need to do not
just because I want to do them but
because I have to do them three years
ago I was serving captain and coat as a
server I feel like a lot of people think
that this happens overnight when it's
really been a lot of work I started a
fat freezing business it just grew from
doing it for friends and family and it
grew into like a crazy thing what's up
you guys it's Graham here I think it's
so important that you live below your
means and live frugally and really focus
on what's most important deal I think
millionaires get a bad rep I try really
hard to serve other people
I
[Music]
growing up I didn't have any anyone in
my family that was it was in real estate
I didn't have anyone in my family that
you know had millions of dollars and so
for me I do remember being like 1516
years having 20 bucks and working
part-time after school and like saving
away all that money then I used that
money to get my real estate license I
barely graduated high school I never
went to college
- divorced parents so I should not have
become wealthy statistically but I
believe that I put in the work and I
really wanted something and I was really
determined and I really enjoyed what I
do and that you know accumulated to
where I am today I literally started
from the bottom I'm not saying that I
was ever homeless or anything but I did
grow up in a single family household we
ended up sharing like a one-bedroom
apartment with five people living in one
bed living through those struggles
really did put into perspective that I
just wanted more out of life so I went
out there and I did whatever it took to
build my wealth and even though all odds
were stacked against me like I failed
out of Business Administration my
counselor told me I would never make it
in business but I took that and it lit a
fire under me to prove her wrong almost
I feel like personally self-made has to
be something that somebody that was
growing up broke in my opinion like you
got it from the bottom and I didn't get
it from the bottom I disagree with that
I don't think you need to come from
straight from the bottom like I started
with a few thousand dollars I know a lot
of people who started their whole
businesses with a few thousand dollars
every few thousand is more than what I
had so much money with a few fancy isn't
gonna make or break your business like
your life like you can't the zero but
let's say you start with a thousand
dollars I still believe yourself maybe
even ten thousand even twenty thousand
because you're not truly like a even six
figures or seven figures I'm broke and I
live at Mom's house with zero dollars
you're in a way better you can you can
mow lawns for a few months and make like
a few thousand dollars like there's way
no how many lawns I'm gonna have
tomorrow it's a lot of lawns but that is
self-made
there's a difference between being poor
and being broke I've been broke before
like me my husband I've been broke many
times in like our relationship but we've
never been poor and even like a long
time ago when I lived in a one-bedroom
apartment with my family we were never
poor I mean I was happy like I had
pudding we went to like parks and stuff
I never felt poor when I was 7 years old
I got kicked out and moved into my
grandparents garage and so I was poor
mentally and I was broke financially and
I had to take care of myself at a very
young age so for a decade I was running
a pool company in order to eventually
gain the opportunities to ultimately
move that ball down the court obviously
so but were you happy I mean I wasn't
not not really right because there was a
lot of stuff going on and like I'm
living in a garage and I'm growing up
and I had to not only become rich fine
financially but also mentally I know
what it's like to have everything and
lose it all
so for me my parents split when I was
young my family was broken my mom had to
then support two children my dad had
some nasty habits with gambling and lost
everything so he had a lot of debts that
my mom ended up having to be chased for
and basically I was 12 years old when I
got my first job going door-to-door
sales selling newspaper subscriptions
and I had to bust my ass off to help my
mom so for me I feel like we all start
from somewhere we go through certain
motions because it builds character I
like that I'm jealous of you guys I wish
I had that mindset like I traveled to
third-world countries to kind of see
what it's like but I still can't put
myself like totally in that spot
I feel like again broken poor are two
different things like I grew up in a
two-parent home I you know went to prom
in a Bentley like I grew up really
really great but then I hit 20 and I
moved out with some boy in the situation
got very very domestic violence you know
I was living in a penthouse and I'm
sorry I got too much pride I wasn't
gonna go back home and you know I'm like
black and blue like getting locked in
like closets like really really toxic
stuff so that from
was very very poor now did it slingshot
me to six-figure a month income yes but
in that state of mind and in that
environment I felt like I was really
poor like I looked beat-up and my direct
deposit was not gonna fix a black eye
you know like
I feel like you know you make more money
you obviously do have to pay somewhat
more but I don't feel like we deserve
extra things to pay just because we have
more money like we shouldn't be looked
to as like a fund you know from the
government or someone else who just
feels like oh you have more money you
should pay more in taxes I just feel
like it should be a little bit more
freedom with it because it's really
really stressful and I feel like a lot
of businesses fail in the first three
years because a tax is not because
they're bad at business not because
they're about it managing money but
because they're not prepared to do
everything by the book I mean I just
don't appreciate it when big companies
who sell a lot of their services like in
the US and then they have some like
Ireland tax status where they're getting
out of it like Apple and Amazon and
these big companies that theoretically
should pay billions in taxes while it's
us average people who are really
supporting the government I think there
should be a little less inequality there
Amazon paid zero dollars in taxes you
see Bezos donating to Australia for the
wildfires he donated $690,000 yeah he
makes an average of two hundred million
dollars per day yeah we put out a whole
press release and I'm just like come on
dude like haha give a little more to be
fair they have created a lot of jobs
through people I actually sell on Amazon
so through Amazon FBA he's provided an
opportunity for people like me to make a
living for myself to be able to start a
business you know online and to be able
to make internet money so like to have
that freedom and like whether we think
that he needs to give more or not I mean
that's really up to him what he does
with his money
[Music]
my husband just got a Lamborghini and he
had Mercedes it was like a 90 grand car
and he added like a 200 grand car and
I'm like why did you do that like you
don't need you know you didn't he's like
well I mean I could so why not like I
want to is fun I'm like you can't even
drive it to the grocery store like you
can't use this car for anything I mean I
grew up wanting cars like I my whole
bedroom was like plastered with cars on
the wall no way I could actually buy it
it was like it's so fun right I was
fulfilling a childhood dream it wasn't
even about the car it was the challenge
yes I had all the cars
the thrill is gone so I don't mean it so
yeah I think that you should all have
like dreams and chase those dreams
whatever they are maybe they don't cost
that much but I mean not everything's
materialistic like when I started making
money yeah I changed my body yeah I mean
I wouldn't cleared my skin yeah I
wouldn't got a tattoo what I would not
like you know what I mean like yeah
don't get hair extensions like I've
definitely purchased things in the past
that were cool and it was because I
could but as times gone along for me
I've realized so many times that every
time I hit the goal or the destination
of the target I realized that the
journey was so much more fun and it and
as I've achieved more success and built
more companies it's almost every time
now where I get there and I'm like man
the journey was actually funner than the
destination I'm kind of over here with
you yeah right
yeah cuz like I used to buy a lot of
bags I'm like no I like and then once I
got there it was kind of like I don't
have a man I hope kids what am i doing
but the question wasn't like what do you
think about what's important now it's
like have you done it in the past you
can't change your past if you do are we
doing the changing the future and what
do you think about material possessions
now like I'll change I don't need them
but in the past I've had them so I've
fulfilled my childhood dreams now I'm
good
three-two-one
if we're talking about getting like
successful inequality is definitely not
a problem like a homeless person has
rose to fame overnight I mean if we're
talking about inequality like with like
the country yeah like you know that
exists but to become successful
I know quality is not a problem you know
anyone can make it I guess the issue
with inequalities that the rich are
getting richer and the poor not having
access to those means well know cuz I
feel like my husband he grew up in like
the ghetto of LA like he had nothing he
worked at lit as a dishwasher technician
and now he drives a gold Lamborghini and
he had a gold Mercedes and he can buy
whatever the hell he wants you don't
need to be like a white guy to make
money you know like you don't need to
grow up in a rich area to make money
there's opportunities everywhere anyone
can do it if they want to buy I think
when you look at statistics statistics
so I think it's definitely doable like
anybody can do it but we still are in a
day in an age where it's it's not as
it's still not that common in the grand
scheme of things like there's still a
lot of people that like you said the
rich get richer and the poor are either
staying the same or not really getting
that ahead right now I feel like there's
still just a lot of inequality I mean
like we're all minorities and you guys
are away and then like growing up if you
put me on fourth grade classroom when I
say show me a millionaire you can say
Apple Amazon Timothy Sykes he's rich and
then you're like okay show me somebody
black show me somebody Asian show me
somebody Spanish you're gonna be like
it's very important it's extremely they
don't know you need more examples
I think the internet democratizes
everything I mean I learned everything
about stock trading on the internet and
many of us take advantage or capitalize
on you know things that are in the
market and the Internet allows us to
become actually say the Internet's a
privilege though no I mean you want to
get like into cement is like it's a
privilege to be alive during this time
in history we have if you're broke you
not you may not have it so you have to
like you can go down the street and you
can get it I have to walk there you
could be paralyzed and you could like
push yourself there's a way to get on
the internet almost every single person
to get on the internet the internet I
think allows you to achieve anything and
it doesn't matter if you're in the u.s.
if you're a man or a woman well I feel
like that's where internet businesses
like for me it's more like beauty like
for example if I didn't like kind of
look good I'm not trying to be conceited
no one would trust me to like help them
look better like for example you're in
stocks that's not really privileged you
learned how to do that my privilege has
allowed me to make money just in that
case just cuz it's like a beauty
industry that's it you know so you can
create privilege then - right once you
gain some momentum in life it becomes
easier in a sense right it become like
you look at the exponential growth of
success typically and once you kind of
create privilege a little bit from what
I've found at least it does become a
little bit easier like once you're there
though I mean it could take ten years to
get there but eventually you create the
privilege doesn't mean you had to start
out privileged for sure and sometimes
it's generational like if I was in my
mom's shoes and I was actually born in
Vietnam and didn't come to and she
didn't take that chance with her family
to leave literally everything behind and
come over to Canada I may not be where I
am today because she didn't you know
make that decision to bring our family
over maybe I would have had to be the
one to make that decision for my family
and then it's the next generation that
basically built off of that so it it
really is situational
because I'm rich 3 2 1
[Music]
we live in a world where social media is
extremely prevalent so like being on
YouTube or Instagram or social media a
lot of it's like perceived you know you
are constantly getting like
quote-unquote judged but even on social
media it really just depends what you
post it that's very much just to control
them just for social media like I am
even if you ask me what time it is I
check my iPhone I don't even know if
this thing works but like when you're
trying to grow your business especially
for me like in stock trading why do you
get into stock trading is it fun no it
sucks but you can make money so for
social media you kind of have to show it
but even with social media I mean if you
have a million subscribers on YouTube I
think you're rich yeah because I know
YouTube is writing you a check and I'm
judging you on direct deposit but that's
my point like you don't have to post a
flashy watch you don't have to post a
nice car anymore like if I see you know
a large amount of subscribers on a
monetized platform I know you're getting
direct deposit I know something's
keeping your lights on now I'm not
judging in a bad way of course you know
I I work every day to try to make videos
too but in the same sense like we judge
people that ask us for money
it's kind of like that poor broke
mentality all over again like if you're
rich and you're like in a domestic
violence relationship like you're not
happy even though you might have money
but still money can buy fun things and
looking back like you're proud of your
accomplishments you're proud of the
journey that you took to get to where
you are and in a way it can back money
allows you to buy freedom and then
freedom gets you the ability to have
more time to find what makes you happy
it's not a direct result but it could be
like let's say your mom or your dad or
somebody that had a severe illness you
know was in the hospital and they had X
amount of time to live now this person
makes you extremely happy and it's gonna
cost a million dollars or two million
dollars for this surgery then they save
them to survive and you save them like
you quite literally just bought
happiness now that's not to say that it
buys happiness in every area of life
like I can but in certain areas like
yeah money definitely can buy how am i
most fulfilling asset is the house that
I bought my parents is I am so grateful
to be able to you were serving another
person under present exactly right it's
like pouring from an empty cup you need
to make sure you fill your cup before
you help other people and I think it
goes back to donating or people expect
you to give more because you have more
but really it's not selfish for you to
want a lot of money or to want that time
freedom and it really just depends on
your definition of happiness what makes
you happy and we all find that I guess
reason at different points in our life
some people figure it out really early
on and some people it takes them a
lifetime to find out what's what makes
them happy so even though you could have
a lot of money if you don't know what
that reason is it drives you to do the
things that you do then really you're
just not going to be happy whether you
have money or not
a big thank you to dash land for
supporting this episode for making our
content possible for those of you who
don't know - Lane is awesome it securely
generates and stores all of your
password information across every device
so you never have to click lost password
again it can start your passport info
your Wi-Fi info your banking info and
even autofill your credit cards so you
never have to go searching through your
wallet which is super great for travel
yeah and speaking of trouble there's
also VPN so you won't be tracked and you
can access content while browsing the
Internet in other countries so for all
you good humans out there make sure you
go to - Lang com / - bleah forget - lame
free on your first device and make sure
you use the code Jubilee when you're
ready to upgrade to premium and get 10%
off make sure to LIKE comment subscribe
and I'll see you next time